$22 TRILLION.
CONGRESS HAS THIS ALL THAT
PROBABLY BY THE SUMMER.
PRESIDENT TRUMP COULD REACH A
BREAKTHROUGH TRADE DEAL WITH
CHINA IN COMING WEEKS.
THE TWO SIDES ARE SAID TO BE
GETTING CLOSER TO AN AGREEMENT
THAT WOULD END THE STANDOFF THAT
HAS KEPT MUCH OF THE WORLD
ECONOMY ON EDGE.
CORRESPONDENT KEVIN CORKE IS AT
THE WHITE HOUSE TONIGHT WITH
SPECIFICS.
WHAT WE KNOW, WHAT WE DON'T.
>> GOOD EVENING.
INCREASINGLY OPTIMISTIC
OFFICIALS TELL FOX NEWS TALKED
WITH CHINA ARE MAKING PROGRESS
BUT THEY ALSO CAUTIONED THERE'S
STILL SOME ISSUES THAT REMAIN
THAT COULD IMPACT THE PACE AND
TIMING OF A RESOLUTION.
>> I AM DEALING WITH CHINA RIGHT
NOW ON A VERY BIG TRADE DEAL, AS
YOU PROBABLY HAVE READ, HEARD,
SOME OF YOU ARE A LITTLE BIT
INVOLVED.
>> WELCOMING ATHLETES AND STATES
ATTORNEYS GENERAL TO THE
WHITE HOUSE, PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
TOP ECONOMIST WAS WELCOMING A
NOTICEABLE IMPROVEMENT IN TRADE
TALKS WITH CHINA.
>> THOSE FOLKS ARE WORKING
REALLY, REALLY HARD TO DELIVER A
DEAL THAT IS NORTH OF 100 PAGES
NOW.
LOTS OF NUANCES AND DETAILS.
I THINK EVERYBODY IS HOPEFUL, AS
THE MARKETS ARE, THAT THIS WILL
GET TO THE FINISH LINE SOMETIME
SOON.
>> SOON COULD BE AN END OF MARCH
MEETING AT MAR-A-LAGO WITH
CHINESE PRESIDENT XI JINPING.
THE PRESIDENT HAS INSTRUCTED HIS
TRADE REPRESENTATIVE TO INFORM
THE FEDERAL REGISTER TOMORROW OF
HIS INTENTION TO KEEP TARIFFS ON
$200 BILLION WITH OF CHINESE
GOODS AT 10% UNTIL FURTHER
NOTICE.
DESPITE POSITIVE MOVEMENT IN THE
TALKS, GAPS REMAIN, INCLUDING
MAJOR DIFFERENCES IN HOW CHINA
LEVEES FEEDS ON U.S. EXPORTS OF
NATURAL GAS, AUTOS, AND
AGRICULTURE PRODUCTS.
THE LATTER OF WHICH SUBJECT TO A
70% TARIFF.
THE PRESIDENT SAID HE WOULD ASK
CHINA TO REMOVE THOSE LEVIES
SINCE HE DIDN'T INCREASE TARIFFS
TO 25% ON MARCH 1.
AMID THE PROGRESS, THERE IS
STILL HEALTHY SKEPTICISM.
>> WE WANT A VERIFIABLE
AGREEMENT THAT WILL HAVE MASSIVE
RETALIATION IF THEY DON'T LIVE
UP TO THE DEAL BECAUSE EVERY
PROMISE CHINA HAS EVER MADE,
THEY VIOLATE.
THEY'VE NEVER LIVED UP TO ANY OF
THIS.
WE HAVE BEEN TALKING WITH THEM
FOR 30 YEARS.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS FACING A
POTENTIAL REVOLT ON CAPITOL HILL
AMONG SEVEN REPUBLICANS OVER HIS
DECISIONS OF CLARA NATIONAL
REGENCY OVER HIS LONG PROMISED
BORDER WALL.
RAND PAUL IS THE LATEST TO BREAK
RANKS, SAYING THAT HE WILL
SUPPORT A MEASURE TO RESTRICT
THE PRESIDENT'S USE OF EXECUTIVE
POWER, A MOVE THAT WILL FORCE
PRESIDENT TRUMP TO USE HIS VETO
PEN FOR THE VERY FIRST TIME.
>> I WILL VOTE FOR THE MOTION TO
DISAPPROVE OF THIS, AND I WILL
CONTINUE TO SPEAK OUT.
I DO BELIEVE THAT THERE IS AT
LEAST TEN REPUBLICAN NO VOTES.
WE WILL SEE, POSSIBLY MORE.
>> SENATE MAJORITY LEADER
MITCH MCCONNELL WILL LIKELY
BRING ABOUT ON THE RESOLUTION TO
THE FLOOR, PROBABLY BEFORE THE
15TH OF MARCH RECESS.
WE ARE TOLD BY OUR CHAD PERGRAM
AND WILL LIKELY HAPPEN ON THE
14TH.
DEMOCRATS COULD TRY TO OVERRIDE
A POSSIBLE VETO BUT TO GET THAT
DONE, THEY NEED 67 VOTES.